el encuentro del xi jinping con vladimir
putin hace apenas un mes fue una
oportunidad para que ambos líderes
firmaran una asociación sin límites
según si más fuerte que una alianza
rusia se ha convertido en el país más
sancionado del mundo pero beijing se ha
negado a condenar rotundamente la
invasión y no ha impuesto ninguna
sanción a moscú nos oponemos firmemente
a las sanciones
el día de la invasión china levantó las
restricciones a las importaciones de
trigo ruso el gigante asiático no solo
quiere más trigo sino también más
materias primas e hidrocarburos lo que
es una buena noticia para rusia putin
también llegó a un acuerdo para
suministrar gas a china a través de un
segundo gasoducto llamado poder de
siberia 2 el primer conducto que conectó
a los dos países se puso en marcha justo
después de que rusia anexar a crimea y
entró en funcionamiento en 2019 mientras
tanto los negocios entre ambos países
continúan como de costumbre esta es la
página web oficial de los productos
rusos que se venden en china ahora todo
está agotado
hoy estoy muy contenta he recibido mis
pedidos mira todo esto son productos
rusos
en este complicado contexto
internacional vemos que podemos contar
con nuestro viejo amigo china china
alivia los daños económicos de las
sanciones internacionales a moscú pero
con cierta cautela por ejemplo desde la
exclusión de los bancos rusos del
sistema swift los bancos chinos
a su rescate